florida governor ron desantis has sent
the entire american left into a tizzy a
now days long national meltdown how did
he do it
he approached 50
of the 2 million illegal aliens per year
that democrats invite into this country
he gave 50 of them 5-0
airplane tickets to martha's vineyard
the fact that that fox news and not the
department of homeland security the city
or local ngos were alerted about a plan
to leave migrants including children on
the side of a busy dc street makes clear
that this is just a cruel premeditated
political stunt this is what they are
doing and a couple more things the
migrants including children
who arrived in martha's vineyard were
misled about where they were being taken
and what would be provided when they
arrived is also deeply alarming
the children governor abbott abandoned
in martha's vineyard the children that
the that
that governor desantis abandon uh as
well
um
you know deserve better they deserve
better than being left on the streets of
dc or being left in martha's vineyard
they deserve deserve a lot better than
that
yeah these people deserve better than to
be left on the streets of washington dc
or martha's vineyard they deserve to be
left on the streets of el paso right
isn't that so much better she also keeps
saying it's the children it's the
children it's it's adults it's adult
people who have come
to america flocking it's true some
children come to america too democrats
have invited millions and millions of
people per year and it's it's good right
it's good to leave them there right
there on the border it's just bad
to leave them in martha's vineyard i
don't mean to disparage el paso i like
texas as much as the next guy but i
don't see very many prominent democrats
wealthy liberal elites buying property
on the border do you
i don't see many wealthy liberals
vacationing in el paso or del rio
i see them all flocking to martha's
vineyard which they boast is a sanctuary
for illegal aliens
so great
that's a win-win right the illegal
aliens come in and texas says to florida
arizona they say we're not a sanctuary
so okay send them up to some of the most
desirable property in the world which
says it is a sanctuary great right
apparently not
the liberal journalist soledad o'brien
summed up the opposition
basically human trafficking she tweeted
cheered on by people who call themselves
christians it's disgusting
but if republicans bringing 50 illegal
aliens to martha's vineyard constitutes
human trafficking
what do you call it when democrats bring
two million illegal aliens per year into
border states and then by the way what
do you call it when democrats do exactly
the same thing that desantis did except
in regular consistent much larger
numbers we got the headlines right here
if the problem is that desantis is
flying illegal aliens around the country
just 50 of them what about what about
this headline
biden sent 70 secret night flights of
migrants from border to florida that's
from the washington examiner what about
this headline
biden administration resumes migrant
flights to suburban new york report
that's in fox news okay you might say
well those are
well the examiner's not right-wing but
you know okay fox news that's a sort of
vaguely right-wing website what about
nbc news i got nbc news right here
biden administration again flying
migrants who cross border in one place
to another before expelling them okay
what about this nbc headline amid border
surge biden administration plans to send
migrants to cities deeper inside u.s
starting with la say internal documents
now
why is it
that when republicans do at a very very
small minuscule level exactly the same
thing democrats have done at a huge
level that's human trafficking in a way
i guess it is human trafficking
in a way
democrats for coming up on 60 years now
have trafficked tens of millions of
illegal aliens into america exposing
them by the way to all manner of
horrific violence on the journey and
violating america's most basic laws in
the process
then when democrats feel like they've
got enough illegals in border states
they fly the migrants to other parts of
the country where they think that
they'll be more politically useful and
then all the while it's lauded as
virtuous and compassionate and as
american as apple pie and then
the moment republicans send even a few
dozen of those very same migrants to the
neighborhoods of wealthy democrats all
of a sudden it's a crime against
humanity
beach season is over there are now lots
of multi-million dollar mansions owned
by open borders democrats all over
martha's vineyard there are ample
opulent accommodations just waiting to
be occupied by people to whom the owners
of those homes promised sanctuary
back when they thought it was impossible
that the migrants would actually show up
for it
i for one say it's time to open up the
doors of those wealthy democrats homes
to all that diversity and strength show
those selfish border state republicans
what true compassion looks like and
governor desantis keeps sending those
lucky illegal aliens up to the vineyard
for a luxury vacation the democrats will
never forget right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code knowles
podcast verizon att t-mobile these guys
take way too much of your money every
month for way more data than you will
ever need which is really really
concerning especially given the current
state of the economy no matter what the
libs tell you we are in a recession
right now it is time to hunker down and
start saving money wherever we can one
of the ways you can do that is by
looking at your current cell phone bill
and realizing that you are paying for
way more data than you need
if that is the case and i'm almost
certain it is then you should talk to my
friends over at puretalk puretalk gives
you myriad choices so that you can
choose the data plan that is right for
you whether that is two gigs per month
or an unlimited plan with a mobile
hotspot by switching to pure talk the
average family of four is saving over 75
dollars every month customers are
realizing that they simply do not need
as much data as they thought plus pure
talk makes it easy to find the right
plan for you and your family they're a
veteran-owned company with a customer
service team based right here in the u.s
they make the switch from your current
provider super easy takes 10 minutes do
it right now join the hundreds of
thousands who are making the switch to
pure talk today this month when you
switch to pure talk you get one month
free
i have loved pure talk for years now
they have never made an offer this big
go to puretalk.com choose your plan
enter code knowles podcast for this
special offer puretalk.com switch to my
cell phone company enter code knowles
podcast get your one month free not in
my backyard that is the democrats
immigration policy
oh yeah open up that border as long as
it's down in el paso as long as it's
down in del rio as long as they're going
to florida as long as the biden
administration can fly the migrants to
wherever they're politically useful
maybe look maybe they'll end up in some
blue cities only some small number of
them all right we'll tolerate that i
guess
but they sure as hell ain't coming to
martha's vineyard oh no
50 migrants 50 oh my gosh think of the
property values though oh
could you imagine and then there might
be a line you know at the local brunch
spot no no no we need to build a big
beautiful wall around martha's vineyard
and keep those migrants out we just have
to send them to border states
the head of the winter home shelter uh
lisa bell castro she's coordinator there
she just came out and summed up i think
the opinion of martha's vineyard
what are the most difficult challenges
right now the difficult challenges are
uh
we have at some point in time they have
to move from here to somewhere else
right we cannot we don't have the
services
to take care of 50 immigrants
and
we certainly don't have housing we're in
a housing crisis as we are on this
island and so
we don't we can't house everyone here
that lives here and works here we don't
have housing for 50 more people
that's tough sounds like you're gonna
have to build some more housing
sounds like you don't oh you don't have
the services set up for well you i guess
you better better get them huh i mean
the federal government spends untold
amounts of money
not only to service illegal immigration
but to actually encourage illegal
immigration so better send some of that
money to martha's vineyard
50 people 50.
it's nothing
that's so few people that's not a drop
of an iota of a fraction of a of even a
slight percentage point
of the illegal immigration that border
states get
so you better figure it out guys oh we
just don't have room what are you
talking about
martha's vineyard is empty right now
people leave martha's vineyard after
labor day
consider the homes that are completely
empty right now
i bet you any home almost any home on
martha's vineyard
could have that is empty right now that
is owned by some wealthy liberal elite
could house
all of the migrants that ron desantis
sent up there they just won't do it
because they would much rather have
red state voters they would much rather
have republicans in texas deal with the
consequences of illegal immigration then
in any way even slightly crack open the
doors to their gazillion dollar mansions
barack obama alone
could house every single migrant
that has been sent to martha's vineyard
barack obama has a 12 million dollar
mansion on martha's vineyard it's almost
7 000 square feet it's got seven
bedrooms but even that okay so seven
bedrooms that could that alone could
probably almost house all of the illegal
immigrants to say nothing of the living
rooms and the sitting rooms and the but
barack obama's got 30 acres
this guy has so much land he's got a
separate barn you can put up a temporary
shelter there you got 30 acres you could
put up many temporary shelters
every every migrant could get at his own
temporary mansion
and he he should do it by the way
if if barack obama wanted a real
political master stroke here he would
open up his home he's got the best
security in the world he doesn't need to
worry about that
he's not even there he could open up his
home
allow the 50 migrants and he would look
like an absolute hero it would be such a
master stroke
but he won't do it
none of these people will do it because
they don't want they don't want the
dirty filthy hoy poloy migrants in their
homes they don't want them in their
backyard they'll talk a really really
good game when the migrants are over a
thousand miles away down on the border
but they don't want these people the
only time that the wealthy democrats of
martha's vineyard are going to allow any
latin americans anywhere near them is
when they're mowing their lawns that's
what it's all about and they'll talk a
really really good game but ultimately
they don't care one little wit about
these people
they certainly don't care about the
millions of them coming each year they
can't even tolerate being near they
can't even tolerate 50 of them being
near their property
much less their themselves or their
families
and so desantis exposes that
and gives these migrants an ice trip to
one of the most desirable locations in
the world great keep it up keep those
plane loads coming baby i'm so glad you
like that clip now
i need you to ring that bell please
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you